my friends he's finally done it Nico one
cologne sure it wasn't a major but I'd
argue it's the next best thing he got to
sing CS Go's final swan song winning one
of the most prestigious trophies in
Esports history before we take the first
step into the next chapter of Cs
the only question is
are we actually done with cs go now
[Music]
when I did my wrap-up of cologne in 2022
I said that the tournament has the power
to sometimes feel more important than an
actual major and I still think that's
true there's just something about the
arena the history and the atmosphere we
always seem to get some of the best
Counter-Strike right here and this year
was shaping up to be no different all of
the storylines were here and there was a
certain finality in the air
[Music]
but before we get into all that we need
to start from the beginning because a
tournament this climactic deserves some
explanation and boy were there a lot of
question marks heading into Germany on
top of the uncertainty around cs2's
release cologne was coming off the tail
of a player break that saw massive
changes liquid is out of North America
Navi signed Alexi B Fallen he's still
playing some seriously crazy was
going on and if your team wasn't one of
the ones making these significant moves
a poor result a cologne would quickly
change that you see many believe that
cologne was going to be the final Ester
Tournament of csgo's life so now is the
time for teams to make a move and end on
a high note so they can carry some
momentum into Counter-Strike too however
for some that sense of urgency just
didn't seem there I'm not saying that
teams like complexity Furia and liquid
need to be making the finals after
making big changes like this but exiting
without making any points is just not
enough from these guys listen
Counter-Strike is a hard game and now
more than ever you get hit with some
very skilled opponents right out the
gate but I couldn't help but feel a bit
disappointed now Navi was another team
that made really big changes and to be
fair at times things did look pretty
rough no one including simple really
performed to the level that they're
capable of but with Alexi B coming in as
igl and the team turning to a more
international roster they did still
manage to knock out a team like FaZe
between two spots and one of them is
simple he met on monster jumps around
and broke he goes back to die to fall to
fail in Cologne then we have astralis
since their original disbanding the team
has been one big question mark despite
having the talent they haven't been able
to secure a result even worth noting
when device came back hopes were high
but many were skeptical including myself
on his ability to perform after such a
long break but as we all know now device
is rust proof throughout the year even
as astralis continued to struggle device
was providing standout performances
however after making some difficult but
necessary changes to the roster leading
up to Cologne it seemed as if things
were finally clicking for the boys with
buzz and blame math providing the proper
support necessary device was able to do
what he does best device trying to find
impact with his awp and I'll stack or
out one back need more okay devices up
put sticker on the floor kicks in
dumping nades and device hunting frags
oh a lineup collateral
fall from device not only did astralis
knockout Navi but once the playoffs
began they continued their run by two
owing heroic unfortunately for all the
device and astralis fans their brilliant
run was cut short thanks to a team with
even more to prove G2 despite winning
cattle earlier that year Nico and
friends were gutted by their lackluster
performance at CS Go's final major the
reality that Nico would never get his CS
go major had set in and the team's
performances started to take a nosedive
it was unclear whether the team was just
reeling or if they were in desperate
need of a shake-up
my guess is that the result of cologne
was going to answer that question but
right out of the gate G2 looked focused
everyone was carrying their weight in
different times in their own ways and it
brought them all the way to the Grand
finals without a loss on the other side
of things were the consistently
underestimated ends and after defeating
the pairs major Champions to make it
there proved once again that they are in
fact the real deal so who is going to
win The Perennial underdogs or the
cursed chokers well if it wasn't already
clear in the matches leading up to the
Grand finals Nico was clearly there to
make a statement his last chance to win
a major slipped through his fingers and
his win at cattle was looking like a
distant flash in the pan winning cologne
was his final opportunity to show the
world why we cared about him in the
first place and folks Nico was out for
blood
the Montana
rotation it's really not easy for Madden
[Applause]
we won't be able to stop that plant JK
yes
anymore he's not and he comes still
catching rotation this gets dicey now
has flashes super awkward now nice from
Nico catches deho on the way in only the
p2k for snappy as Nico doesn't
need to see his opponent but no nuts
Nails it with the deagle
her Senpai has done enough can they
really recover this with only the one
rifle Nico doesn't think so util
deployed Nico poised needs a tap and in
signature need go fashion he's made it a
one-on-one nurse what have you got for
us he's off the ball Nico strikes
despite clawing out a win on map 3 hence
just didn't have an answer for the
combined Firepower of both modesty and
Nico together the two had a combined 183
kills and both got plus 1.4 ratings and
for their efforts they got to walk home
with what might BCS goes final for well
in this
[Applause]
23.
now how will this affect Nico's Legacy
well that all depends on what you value
and how you really look at things Nico
already has his fair share of silverware
and winning cologne just netted him yet
another MVP award if he retires tomorrow
he'll have a better career than 99 of
players and if this ends up being CS
Go's final big Lan event that's a pretty
damn cool achievement however that still
is a pretty big if you see despite
cologne having an epic atmosphere
machine in a tailed suit and a literal
moment of silence for the death of Cs go
we still have no idea when CS2 is coming
out and what that transition is going to
look like at one point we thought Dallas
was going to be the final event but two
months later and I'm still here talking
CS go now there are some smaller events
that are obviously going to be played in
CS go but we still have IEM Sydney and
blast later this year hell pro league is
in three weeks if CS2 comes out before
then will the switch be instantaneous
does valve let the protein continue with
go until they feel comfortable enough to
make the switch and if so how long does
that take there does seem to be some
time in September where a transition and
release period could be viable but
knowing valve
nothing's a certainty regardless I
personally think ripping it off like a
Band-Aid is the best bet listen it's
never going to be a perfect time to
release CS2 and regardless of when it
does someone's going to be upset all I
know is that clone was a banger and
although the moment of Silent does feel
a bit premature that was the last time
in the cathedral until the next era of
Counter-Strike unless valve somehow
up this release like really badly
but that's not gonna happen
right
truth be told I wanted I wanted ants to
win just an easy for ants meme for the
last cologne would be pretty hilarious
they're a great team but
boy that was a big spanking there's been
worse but that was bad and Nico got his
he got his cologne for that I'm happy
for him